الناخبون الامريكيون يدلون باصواتهم في
الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس اضافه الى
انتخاب حكام معظم الولايات ومسؤوليها
المحليين وكذلك المجالس التشريعيه
للولايات معركه التجديد النصفي في
الكونغرس بالتحديد مع ليون بها 35 مقعدا
من مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ المئه وكل المقاعد
ال 435 في مجلس النواب
اخر الاستطلاعات الخاصه بمجلس الشيوخ
تضعوا ست ولايات في خانه الولايات
المتارجحه من نظر لتقارب مرشحي الحزبين
فيها هذه الولايات هي جورجيا وبن سلفانيا
واذا حصل الجمهوري هنا على ثلاثه منها
فيرجح فوزهم بالاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ
اما في مجلس النواب فيشتد التنافس بين
الحزبين في نحو 34 مقعدا متارجحا و تشير
استطلاعات الراي الى تفوق محتمل للحزب
الجمهوري في انتخابات مجلس النواب والفوز
بما بين 10 و20 مقعدا ما يكفي لحصوله على
الاغلبيه